اعد الهجوم الاسرائيلي على مخيم جنين الى
دائره الضوء موضوع التنسيق الامني بين
السلطه الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال لا سيما
مع اعلان السلطه انه لم يعد قائما وهذه
ليست المره الاولى
مع حكومه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لم يعد
قائما اعتبارا من الان
التنسيق الامني هو تعاون بين الاجهزه
الامنيه الفلسطينيه والمخابرات
الاسرائيليه برعايه امريكيه من خلال
اتفاقيات وخطوات عده اتخذت لتثبيته
البدايه باتفاق اوسلو عام
1993 الذي يلزم السلطه الفلسطينيه بمسمائه
الاتفاق محاربه الارهاب ويعني عمليا
مواجهه فصائل المقاومه ويجعل التنسيق
السلطه مسؤوله عن اتخاذ الاجراءات
المناسبه ضد النشيطين ومقاتلين الفصائل من
خلال التعاون امنيه مع اسرائيل
لكن التنسيق لم ياتي اكوله اندلعت
الانتفاضه الفلسطينيه الثانيه او ما سميت
انتفاضه الاقصى لم يفلح للتنسيق الامني
ولا عنف قوات الاحتلال في وقتها او الحد
من زخمها ثم اتى اتفاق طاب الموقعه عام
وقعت السلطه الاتفاق الذي نص على مهام
اللجنه المشتركه للتنسيق الامني لنصل عام
2005 حيث قاد الجنرال الامريكي كيف دايت
اجتماعات بدات في اذان مارس عام 2005 اي
بعد ايام من انتهاء الانتفاضه الثانيه
لتنظيم الجانب التنفيذي للاتفاق الامني
اشرف ديتا على اعداد وتدريب اجهزه الامن
الفلسطينيه وفرض عقيده امنيه جديده على
المؤسسه الامنيه في السلطه لصناعه ما سميه
الفلسطيني الجديد ومنذ ذلك الحين لحقت
السلطه الفلسطينيه انتقادات كثيره بشان
تعاونها مع السلطات الاسرائيليه حيث وصفت
تنسيق بانه من طرف واحد الا ان المشهد
اليوم بالضفه مع تشكيل فصائل جديده مثل
كتيبه جنين وعارن الاسود في نابلس يضع
جدول التنسيق الامني على المحك